look we have we have stepped away from
traditional relationships and the cat's
out the back it doesn't work right this
this cook-up culture is bad for
everybody yeah it's bad for everybody
and america's leading and leading the
charge on this [ __ ] with you know
women's live and all that garbage and we
don't talk about the hyper sexualization
of women because it's hilarious how
women are like oh i'm empowered i'm
gonna go and like
have a bunch of dudes [ __ ] me and throw
me away yeah
like i get what you're wearing
i'm saying like that's not a win that's
you're catching l's and then yeah like
if you look at the stats women's hit
since like the 1970s in america women's
happiness has been consistently
declining the more they stray away from
traditionalism is this not like a
patriarchy thing or a white male
oppressing people thing look around the
globe look at africa look at india look
at asia look at you know the middle east
look at south america every type of
people since the dawn of civilization
has engaged in these traditional type of
relationships
gender roles it is for sure it is only
recently where they say like okay let's
let's step away from this let's like you
know we gotta smash the patriarchy or
whatever trash they're putting out there
and the people who follow it are
miserable she's here she's happy she's
feminist she's attractive she's
successful and she's married though
that's exactly she was still single
right now she'd be singing a different
tune
and here's my point i don't i think
single girls are miserable well it's my
point is that i don't think that women
and men for that matter are ready to
acknowledge what you just said well they
need to grow the [ __ ] up well and hear
me out because you know i cite this
report all the time
there's a report out there about that by
2030 so in eight years from now
the majority of working women okay so
that's ages you know 25 to 45 right
working women
um by 2030 45 of them are going to be
unmarried and no kids so women who are
38 years old
are going to look and say
i've been working my ass off since i'm
21 years old i've been encouraged to go
to school get a job i don't need no man
i'm going to become a boss baby ceo
and they're going to look at themselves
and they're turning 40 next year and the
next day and they're going to be like
i've got a couple hundred grand in the
bank no man no kids couple cats i've got
one egg left what am i gonna like
so i don't think one good one so it's
hard to tell a woman who's 30 today
right hey you're making all the wrong
decisions you're focusing way too much
on your career not on your personal life
or your sexual life or finding a husband
it's very hard that they're like dude
i'm just starting to make money for like
get out of here yeah so the reality is
not going to set in now it might be ten
years from now right right you feel me
on that i don't think the reality is
going to set in ever i think they're
going to march they're just going to
double down you're going to be marching
to their [ __ ] grave i swear to god
because there's always a come to jesus
moment they're like what have i been
thinking and when they come to jesus
usually it's too late
that's my point there's there well okay
then if you think they'll come to jesus
and be too late
yes but i mean there's gonna be an
epiphany but like what have i been doing
all this for but we also have an only
fans culture
which is recent yeah which is recent in
sweden they actually did put out a um a
questionnaire about it in schools yeah
and tons of girls answered they want to
quit school and make money on only fans
yeah because everyone wants to get rich
quick these days so who the hell wants
to do four years of school find a career
yeah get an internship do it get your
first job study hate it study
get an issue with your boss
move from job to job move like who wants
to do that who wants to work hard when
you can make some easy money but it
makes an issue today yeah but it is an
issue because most of the guys
don't want to date an only fans girl so
if you like that clip click right here
to watch another or if you want to watch
the entire saucecast click right here
[Music]